escribe siete octavos como un número
decimal y bueno el chiste aquí es
recordar que siete octavos es
exactamente lo mismo que tomar el siete
y dividirlo entre ocho que después
también se puede escribir esta forma ya
tomamos el 7 le ponemos su casita y lo
dividimos entre 8 y lo que quede aquí
eso es justo 7 entre 8 que es
exactamente lo mismo que siete octavos
entonces pues vamos a hacer esta
división no ponemos aquí nuestros 7 y
vamos a dividirlo entre 8
porque aquí podemos notar que el 8 no
cabe en el 7 entonces seguro vamos a
necesitar poner unos decimales entonces
podemos empezar por poner aquí el
decimal y aquí también va a ir el
decimal y pues a la derecha del punto
siempre podemos poner más ceros aquí
podría poner una infinidad pero pues
creo que con tres es suficiente y bueno
el 8 definitivamente no cabe dentro del
7 pero si cabe dentro del 70 y a ver
déjame pienso 8 x 8 64 64 está muy cerca
del 70 no entonces vamos a poner un 8
por acá y entonces 8 por 8 64 64 que le
vamos a restar 70
y 70 menos 64 son 6 o sea el 8 que hace
exactamente ocho veces en el 70 y además
les sobran 6 ya ahora pues vamos a bajar
uno de estos ceros
entonces tenemos aquí 60 y este es que
dicen cuántas veces cabe el 8 en 60 pues
justo aquí tenemos que el 8 acabe 8
veces en el 64 entonces yo creo que con
el 7 ya tenemos suficiente a ver vamos a
ver 8 por 7 cuánto es 8 por 7 son 56
y los tenemos que restar
y entonces 60 menos 56 son 4 y bueno
tenemos que seguir viviendo
tenemos que seguir agregando ceros a la
derecha y bajando los porque todavía
tenemos un residuo y bueno por el
momento vamos a confiar en que esta
división va a acabar en algún punto
porque pues puede pasar que esta
división nos lleve una eternidad o sea
puede haber una cantidad infinita de
números a la derecha de este punto pero
estamos confiando en que este no es uno
de esos casos y bueno cuando es el caso
tampoco es que tengas que quedar ahí
todo el tiempo sacamos todos los números
hay otras formas de lidiar con eso pero
bueno entonces tenemos que bajar este
cero
y ahora sí cuantas veces creen que cabe
el 8 dentro de 40 a veces es un poquito
como atinarle pero yo me acuerdo 8 por 5
entonces 8 por 540
y ahora sí tenemos residuos cero como
tenemos residuos cero ya tenemos cuánto
es exactamente 7 entre 8 y entonces ya
terminamos de escribir a 7 octavos como
un número decimal siete octavos es
exactamente punto ocho siete cinco y
generalmente me gusta escribir un cero
antes del punto decimal para remarcar
que justo ahí es donde está el punto
decimal porque hay entonces ya
terminamos de escribir a siete octavos
como un número decimal